bonjour à tous il est 11h 4 merci à vous
de nous suivre aujourd'hui en direct sur
lefigaro.fr mais aussi sur notre page
youtube notre page figaro live à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du procès des
attentats du 13 novembre une nuit bien
sûr qui a traumatisé tout le pays alors
l'audience doit s'ouvrir dans à peu près
une heure et demie elle démarrera à
12h30 et vous verrez sur ces images
fournies en direct par l' agence
france-presse
france presque
de nombreuses personnes sont déjà dans
la salle des pas perdus
des parties civiles donc il y en a des
centaines et des centaines qui sont
attendus trois cent cinquante avocats
c'est un procès donc hors norme qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui et que vous pourrez
suivre en direct donc sur lefigaro.fr
grâce à notre live texte de guillaume
points et de esther paolini esther
paolini qui est journaliste fait divers
au figaro et que nous essayons de
joindre mais effectivement le réseau
n'est pas très bon dans cette salle des
pas perdus nous allons également revenir
sur cette soirée du 13 novembre mais pas
que avec philippe de paris qui est en
plateau avec moi mon invité aujourd'hui
je le remercie bonjour philippe de paris
bonjour l'homme versiontracker bonjour
alors je vous présente donc vous êtes
auteur de ce livre de ce roman hauteur
de berry les formes de l'ombre et vous
étiez opérateurs à la berri et vous
n'avez notamment opéré le soir du 13
novembre au bataclan on reviendra sur ça
mais surtout en détail sur sur votre
livre sur votre polar qu'elle dans
quelques instants tout de suite on va
aller sur place puisque nous avons notre
reporter thibault timoré qui est devant
les grilles du palais de la justice
thibault qu'elle est un petit peu le
dispositif de sécurité il est
impressionnant en ce jour d'ouverture du
procès
bonjour brune bonjour à tous merci de
nous rejoindre sur son figaro life c'est
un dispositif en effet impressionnant
mais surtout unique est assez historique
puisque et bien pour la première fois et
surtout pour une paire être donc des
neuf mois de ce procès écrit sur à
partir d'aujourd'hui est donc qui se
tiendra du mardi au vendredi et bien
l'île de la cité au long plein coeur de
paris est tout à fait quadrillé
désormais par les forces de l'ordre avec
une présence extrêmement encore un des
policiers et des gendarmes qui sont
venus et bien faire déjà la circulation
avec une circulation extrêmement
impact et aux alentours de sept îles de
la cité et donc bien un dispositif comme
vous le disiez assez impressionnant
puisqu'il faut dire pour l'essentiel des
des différentes mesures qui vont avoir
lieu lors de ce procès eh bien
les forces de l'ordre ont de voir un
petit peu interagir au fur à mesure des
journées et les déplacements à commencer
bien évidemment par le déplacement des
accusés qui devront et bien se rendre
chaque jour ici derrière moi dans le
palais de justice et donc ils seront
escortés par les forces du gign mais
également les forces des eris les forces
des eris ce sont les forces de
l'administration pénitentiaire que l'on
appelle les équipes régionales
d'intervention et de sécurité et qui
donc est bien vont se charger d'une
escorte de ces accusés ont également et
bien de nombreux dispositifs les forces
de l'ordre autour de moi vous pouvez le
voir avec ici quelques camions derrière
moi des forces de gendarmerie
on n'a pas eu de détails précis sur les
effectifs est en tout cas sur les
les différentes mesures qui ont été
prises ici par les autorités puisque
bien on imagine bien que d importantes
mesures de sécurité sont sont à prendre
en terme de communication sur ses
effectifs toutefois bien vous le voyez
autour de moi le boulevard du palais qui
donc est bien précède l'entrée du palais
de justice et lui tout à fait quadrillé
elle sera pendant l'ensemble de ce
procès de l'autre côté bien tout
l'ensemble de l'île de la cité et lui
aussi quadrillé avec d'un côté le
célèbre quai des orfèvres qui lui est
temporaire et est apprécié à riom il est
impossible d'y accéder de l'autre côté
le quai de l'horloge est également
difficile accéder et enfin un accès
spécial est lui réservé aux journalistes
qui sont accrédités on a plus de 141
médias qui ont été accrédités de son de
58 pays différents et donc eh bien ces
accès ce fonds est bien derrière au nord
de l'île de la cité c'est donc désormais
bien plus de la moitié de l'île de la
cité pour les neuf mois à venir qui va
être bien presque paralysé j'ai envie de
dire brulotte
suivent déjà sur les tchats du figaro.fr
et sur la page youtube je salue multi
nino 05 qui nous demande bonjour allez
vous couvrir l'intégralité du procès
alors effectivement ce procès va se
dérouler pendant neuf mois donc nous
n'allons pas couvrir toutes les
audiences mais les étapes clés bien sûr
seront à suivre sur figaro live mais
aussi sur le figaro.fr beaucoup de nos
journées ils vont vous faire vivre le
procès de l'intérieur notamment les
comptes rendus des audiences je pense
notamment à stéphane durand souffland
notre plume du service société mais
aussi paul gonzalez ou jean kikizo là
qui sont trois journalistes qui vont
suivre ce procès mais également comme je
vous le disais en introduction esther
paolini qui est actuellement dans la
salle des pas perdus et qui va assister
à cette première audience les temps
forts on va dire que le prochain temps
fort de ce procès se déroulera à la fin
du mois à partir du 28 septembre où
quand vous démarrez les audiences les
auditions des premières parties civiles
des premières familles de victimes ou
encore des rescapés de ces attentats et
cela devrait durer un mois nous allons
évidemment recouvrir à nouveau ce
nouveau temps fort du procès vous
pourrez le suivre sur figaro live et sur
le figaro.fr delphine farah qui nous
pose une question peut-être thibault si
vous nous entendez vous pourrez répondre
à cette question bonjour pouvons nous
suivre cette audience en live en direct
tout à fait brune alors il faut pour
vous expliquer un petit peu les excès
bien c'est une séance publique
évidemment de justice comme on en a
l'habitude ici au palais de justice
alors d'habitude ce serait plutôt dans
l'autre pas la justice de paille mais
bien pour ce panel justice qui va
accueillir des personnes de façon assez
exceptionnelle puisque le palais a été
bien spécialement aménagée avec par
exemple des couloirs spéciaux qui ont
été construits spécialement pour les
accusés afin de leur permettre d'accéder
au palais de justice de façon sécurisée
et donc bien si vous en tant que citoyen
vous souhaitez pouvoir suivre en fait
c'est ces différentes séances qui vont
avoir lieu
il va falloir vous rendre ici même à
paris avec bien cet accès qui se trouve
juste derrière moi pardon on est un peu
en contre jour et qui donc bien permet
au citoyen comme bien cela fonctionne en
démocratie de suivre ces séances de
justice
et pour le programme de la journée pour
répondre donc à multi nino 0,5
aujourd'hui donc va démarrer
l'audition enfin l'appelle plutôt des
près de 1800 parties civiles constituées
dans ce dossier donc ça risque de durer
trois jours sur les trois prochains
jours
seulement l'appel de 2,6 ses 1800
particules qui sont des rescapés ou des
familles de victimes ou des associations
de victimes
voilà pour le programme de la journée en
tout cas ce soir il y aura également un
décryptage de la première journée avec
paul gonzalez à suivre sur point de vue
en direct sur figaro live nous
reviendrons dans quelques instants donc
au direct avec thibault il aurait un
petit peu plus tard mais mais mais tout
d'abord je souhaite donc laissé un petit
peu la parole à mon invité sur place qui
nous fait le plaisir d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui philippe de paris donc je
rappelle pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
que vous êtes ancien opérateur de la
berri et auteur donc de ce roman de ce
polar berry les formes de l'ombre publié
aux éditions mareuil
donc pour ceux qui nous regardent et qui
sont peut-être qu'ils demandent pourquoi
vous vous gardez votre masque donc vous
êtes toujours en activité et par souci
de confidentialité vous préféré
témoigner donc à visage à moitié couvert
donc masqué et vous garderez donc cette
casquette tout au long de notre
entretien
première question philippe de paris
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
d'écrire envie d'écrire ce livre est ce
que c'est le 13 novembre justement pas
du tout pas du tout c'est
essentiellement lié à un événement qui
s'est passé dans ma vie personnelle et
professionnelle
j'ai décidé
de façon un peu inopinée de me lancer
dans l'écriture sans savoir trop ça des
monnaies
finalement je suis arrivé à
l'aboutissement de ce livre les formes
de l'ombre au bout de quelques mois
combien de mois vous a très justement
l'écriture il m'a pris trois mois à peu
près et c'est cette cette chose qui
s'est passé dans votre vie est ce qu'on
peut le savoir où c'est trop c'est trop
c'est un petit pré votre job donc non
c'est pas l'évoquer ça pas de nécessité
mais
finalement tant mieux puisque ça m'a
permis de me lancer dans une aventure
que je n'aurais certainement jamais
tenté si ce n'était pas arrivé
alors le 13 novembre aujourd'hui donc
évidemment on parle beaucoup du 13
novembre effectivement c'est le procès
qui s'ouvre et le très souvent c'est une
nuit que tous les parisiens ont
évidemment
en mémoire ses nuits gravé en mémoire de
tous les parisiens et de tous les
français évidemment on sait tous ce
qu'on faisait ce soir là avec qui on
était
qu'est ce qu'on faisait au moment où ces
événements sont arrivés vous philippe de
paris où étiez-vous cette soirée du 13
ans d'à côté ce soir là je me rendais au
restaurant j'ai des petits problèmes
personnels j'allais au restaurant avec
ma compagne de l'époque
sur le chemin ça commence et jusque vers
21h donc son chemin ça commençait déjà à
biper les premières informations que
j'avais reçu c'était effectivement les
explosions au stade de france on savait
pas trop ce que ça pouvait être c'était
le les les pétards étaient envisagées
les bombes agricoles également donc tant
qu'on n'avait pas de d'éléments on est
resté sur une soirée respectives et on
arrive à en restaurant là j'ai reçu un
message où effectivement ça se précise
et il fallait effectuer un retour
service
donc quand je crois que sur le coup une
des gares ma situation personnelle je
n'étais pas
j'étais pas emballé je vais pas vous
mentir je n'étais pas emballé et puis
deux minutes après je me suis retrouvé
au volant d'un véhicule a glissé les
feux rouges pour retourner rapidement au
service parce que il était aux alentours
de 21h 6 à 9 certainement au niveau
temporalité je pourrais même pas moins
six tués parce que j'ai pas prêté
attention
il vous étiez déjà arrivé au restaurant
avec moi tout court est en train de
s'installer rica qu'est ce que vous lui
avez dit à ce moment là parce que je
vous ai dit je dis franchement je suis
promis d'y aller mais c'était vraiment
lié par rapport à ma situation
personnelle après ce que je vous disais
deux minutes après j'étais en train de
glisser les feux rouges pour retourner à
mon unité mais c'est vrai que sur le
coup
par rapport à ma situation
à l'instant t j'avais d'autres choses en
tête je devais partir le lendemain en
congé en fleurs pour un petit week-end
donc c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas prévisible et finalement
on nous demande de répondre à la
prévisible et que s'adapter c'est ce que
j'ai fait c'est ce que tous mes
collègues ont fait est qu'elle a été le
déroulé de votre soirée après à partir
du moment où vous avez répondu présent à
cet appel comment on comment ça se passe
concrètement ça s'enchaîne rapidement
vous savez je suis arrivé sur place au
fur et à mesure où les collègues y
arriver on équiper des véhicules on
s'est projeté directement sur les sons
la zone en fait et quels sont les les
ordres vous êtes vous est projeté à quel
endroit à ce moment là du coup alors moi
comme j'arrive je fais pas partir de là
je fais pas partie de cette première
vague de cette première colonne la
colonne alpha qui est arrivé rapidement
sur place nous on s'est équipé les
consignes étaient de 2
de converger vers le bataclan parce
qu'on savait à 7 à cet instant que
qu'une prise d'otages étaient avérés sur
place les décisions c'était encore sur
place soit là c'est à dire quelque chose
d'inhérent comme au départ vous deviez
être en renfort du coût de la colonne
alpha qui a mené l'assaut contre les
terroristes au bataclan c'est ça alors
en fait non auriez eu les deux colonnes
qui se sont mises en place si vous
voulez le bataclan c'est en termes
d'infrastructures c'est un u oui c'est
un open space donc ça a eu on va faire à
cheval comme vous voulez il y avait deux
portes d'accès en symétrie donc un accès
où se trouvait la colonne alpha avec une
présence avérée et l'accès au niveau de
la colonne bravo ou
hypothétiquement il pouvait
avoir une menace parce qu'on n'allait
pas encore enfin on savait pas
exactement
finalement
c'est la problématique
et kehl j'imagine que tout ça se fait
dans l'urgence est-ce que vous avez le
temps d'avoir des émotions qui vous
traverse est ce que vous réalisez ce que
vous êtes en train de faire à ce moment
là
pour avoir vécu les événements du
du 8 janvier l'hyper cacher donc on
avait une petite idée de ce que c'était
après la prise de conscience honnêtement
elle se fait se fait sur place dès que
vous arrivez à des cons à rue parce que
des policiers partout
il ya des victimes partout c'est une
boucherie voilà le mot exact c'est ça
c'est une boucherie et alors vous
pénétrez dans dans le bataclan qu'elle
est et quel a été votre premier ressenti
à ce moment là
le premier est senti que j'ai eu en
voyant toutes ces personnes
à terre ça a été je ne pense pas voilà
je me suis c'était mon mode de
fonctionnement
à ce moment là de me focaliser vraiment
sur son mon travail en occultant
je veux dire le plus possible ce qui ce
qui se passait autour de moi en dehors
de nos objectifs deux objectifs
principaux
alors justement dans votre livre vous
vos personnages font
fonds ne prenne pas un exercice
justement qui ressemble vaguement on va
dire enfin même beaucoup à cet épisode
du bataclan un exercice terroristes
est ce que vous aviez été préparés à ce
genre de tueries de masse bien préparé
avant d'intervenir justement sur le
bataclan où c'est après le 13 novembre
que que vous avez reçu plus de
l'exercice de ce type là les procès déjà
en place à l'époque avait déjà commencé
avant les événements de janvier
forcément de fil en aiguille sont
perfectionnés les entraînements étaient
de plus en plus poussée
au delà du 13 novembre par la suite on a
continué à se perfectionner à
s'améliorer en fait on se sert de notre
vécu pour pouvoir progresser ce qui a
une base dans notre métier on reste pas
sur des choses acquises si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes toujours en direct
à l'occasion de l'ouverture du procès
des attentats du 13 novembre avec nos
journalistes sur place que nous essayons
de rejoindre et la connexion n'est pas
toujours facile et en plateau avec
philippe de paris donc ancien opérateur
de la berri et auteur d'un roman polar
d'un roman policier intitulé berry les
forces de l'ombre publié aux éditions
mareuil on revient sur ce métier
notamment va revenir sur le métier de
policier d'élite qui est dépeint dans ce
roman merci à vous tous de nous suivre
en direct merci je vais vous saluer dans
le tchat sur youtube merci à un drain
droitards qui me dit merci pour pour ce
live est également jean callas tv qui
nous suit et france animaux qui nous
fait part de de son témoignage de ce
qu'elle faisait ou de ce qu'il faisait
ce soir du du 14 du 13 novembre
videmment c'est une soirée qui a marqué
tous les français comme on le comme on
le disait
philippe de paris
comment votre famille on va dire vous
vous évoquez tout à l'heure que vous
étiez avec votre ex compagne puis le
moment vous avez été appelé on va dire
comment vous gérez le stress de votre
famille qui du coup peuvent suivre tous
ces événements en direct à la télévision
comment vous vous leur annoncer ça et
comment et comment ils gèrent ce stress
on va dire sous la halle inverse de ce
qui s'est passé en début d'année il n'y
avait pas finalement de retransmission
audiovisuelle
l'hyper cacher c'est un événement qui
était médiatisée c'est en open space
donc les caméras avaient plus facilement
accès à
l'image donc ce qui a été peut-être plus
compliqué je prends mon nom bien sûr
pour ma famille étant donné que c'était
du direct de vivre les événements moi
personnellement moi je peux parler mes
collègues qu'on est dedans les tenants
voilà on est dans notre vous n'avez
notre message à votre famille ça va ça
va bien je fais si je fais ça vous êtes
moi personnellement je n'ai pas fait je
préfère rester
focalisés par ce que j'ai à faire
à l'issue bien sûr j'ai envoyé des
messages quoi qu'il en soit dans mon
mode de fonctionnement je préfère
vraiment rester dans ma bulle sur
l'événement et pas me disperser avec
avec des messages mais ça c'est ma façon
de faire ce que ce qu'ils m'ont engagé
que moi après c'est vrai que pour la
famille par rapport à des événements de
janvier il n'y avait absolument
aucune image en suivait mais voilà bien
cacher c'est en direct le m'attaque ans
quand même entre nîmes et plus à huis
clos donc mais votre famille c'est avec
vous aviez été envoyé en tout cas votre
ex compagne savez que vous étiez donc
j'imagine que toute la nuit elle a dû
suivre avec panique et intérêts on va
dire la chaîne d'info en continu ou la
radio
surprendre mais on n'a pas parlé savait
pas comment elle a vécu cette soirée
ouest comme je vous l'avais vu qu'au
départ je devais partir le lendemain et
après cet assaut qui après cette
intervention qui a été je trouve assez
un finalement rapide on s'est retrouvé
enfin j'ai senti je me suis retrouvée
finalement avec un espèce de vide en
rentrant chez moi parce qu'on est passé
de quelque chose d'émotionnel très fort
à une situation on se retrouve
finalement vasco dans sa famille où tout
est retombé ce qui avait bloqué un
collègue effectivement n'est pas ce
système de sas vous savez un peu pour
pour avoir cet intermédiaire ça ce qu'on
avait eu à l'époque où
[Musique]
et les évènements libère cacher le soir
comme c'était relativement tôt dans la
soirée on s'était tous retrouvés au
restaurant à l'époque j'étais un bagnard
d'intervention on s'était tous retrouvés
au restaurant ça nous avait permis de
décompression d'aller passer un moment
entre nous différents et avant de
rejoindre ma famille moi ça m'avait
plutôt bien aidé j'avais trouvé ça j'ai
trouvé une note finalement sympathique
si je puis dire un peu plus humaine
avant de retrouver chez moi là soit là
je suis rentré chez moi est
effectivement j'avais ce
ça s'arrête net finalement et
la première chose que ma compagne m'a
demandé c'est bon ok demain on part pas
judici donnant pas j'avais vu avec mon
commandant il y avait suffisamment de
monde l ai dit tu reviens lendemain et
tu reviens dès que possible ce qui m'a
vous avez réussi à vous détacher de
cette actualité j'ai réussi à me
déconnecter jeu sap a été un week-end
extraordinaire non plus mais si vous
voulez le fait de passer finalement de
cet événement riche en émotions très
intense et très fort à me retrouver le
lendemain à 10h en train de marcher au
bord d'une plage avec le soleil ça a été
un peu mon ça a été mon sens finalement
c'est ce qui m'a à mon sens a permis de
2,2 de mieux vivre l'émotion mieux vivre
l'événement d'avoir ce
ce petit échappatoire mieux vivre
l'événement justement si on revient à
cette soirée de vous dites que pour vous
c'est allé très très vite dans votre
tête pourquoi c'est dû au stress c'est
dû à la situation c'est
séduire l'action en elle-même relation
était relative a été très rapide
c'est une intervention qui s'est
déroulée
elle aurait pu livrer beaucoup plus
longtemps que ça et c'était
quelque chose de rendement menez est à
mon sens très rapide après vous savez
quand j très rapide c'est surtout le
fait de se retrouver voyez si on
séquence un petit peu ça commence le
soir vers 21h je suis au restaurant je
pars sur quelque chose de très fort je
me retrouve rapidement dans une chez moi
après cette intervention est finalement
le laps de temps entre les deux il est
pas énorme l'hyper cacher c'est quelque
chose qui s'est déroulé sur plusieurs
jours parce que la traque c'était
fatigant c'était très contraignant
emotionnellement également et il a fallu
l'afflux gérer en fait plus a donc là
effectivement elle a versé quelque chose
qui a été essayé une intervention qui
était plus courte est ce que vous
comprenez justement les polémiques qui
ont été apportées sur la lenteur de
cette intervention vu que justement vous
qui étiez sur le terrain témoigner à
linverse en disant que c'était très
rapide c'était une toute façon c'était
un assaut qui qui est remarquable de à
tous points de vue
qui a été menée en bonne et due forme
est ce que vous comprenez du coup qu'on
puisse critiquer
cette intervention que vous avez menée
le 13 novembre c'est je n'entrais pas
dans cette polémique
il me semble d'ailleurs que monsieur
cazeneuve qui était mise à l'intérieur à
l'époque a répondu à toutes ces attaques
sur un reportage sur arte tout à fait à
la suite d'un reportage fait pas très
bien fait c'est à mon sens c'est pas moi
de le faire ce qui menace par contre
c'était une époque à un moment où on
devrait avoir un sentiment d'unité
nationale il ya des critiques qui sont
peu laudative en faire labeyrie les
forces de l'ordre qui ont surtout à mon
sens aucun lieu d'être
vous n'avez pas ça n'avait pas lieu
d'être
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
toujours en direct donc avec philippe de
paris ancien opérateur de la berri et
auteur de ce roman que je remonte à
l'écran béryl et les forces de londres
de l'ombre pardon vous pouvez poser
d'ailleurs vos questions ou vous pouvez
donnez vos commentaires je vous lis et
je les relais ray en direct si vous avez
des questions à poser à philippe de
paris sur sur le métier de policier
d'élite justement dans votre roman si on
revient à votre roman vous faites
allusion à cette soirée on va dire par
bribes notamment pour expliquer que vos
personnages ont été marqués qu'il ya eu
comme un avant et un après 13 novembre
en quoi cet épisode vous a marqué en
tant que policier d'élite et puis en
tant qu'homme alors je me permets juste
de vous faire une petite remarque à
aucun moment finalement j'évoque le 13
novembre dans ce livre nous sommes
d'intervention que j'ai regroupé
dans ce roman parce que je voulais sur
une période très courte faire découvrir
aux lecteurs finalement le panel des
missions qui étaient dévolues à l'unité
voilà notamment sur l'exercice
terroristes c'est un exercice comme un
autre vous expliquez que vos personnages
ont déjà eu à tout à fait voilà
effectivement il ya un petit un petit
parallèle on va le dire avec
effectivement ça ressemble étrangement à
7 toutes ces scène du bataclan qu'on a
entendu des témoignages des policiers
qui ont eu à entrer dans une salle avec
beaucoup de corps de victimes par terre
et notamment ses skis et reproduit dans
l'exercice dans votre roman c'est pour
ça que je dis que c'est par bribes c'est
des petites allusions vous fait des pas
des adhésions directes mais vous
expliquer notamment que vos personnages
ont été marqués par ce cet épisode parce
qu'ils n'ont vécu mais j'ai mangé fait
des évocations j'ai fait des petites
pascal mais surtout c'est important de
de signification c'est une fiction mais
est ce que vous vous basez également sur
du vécu c'est évident sinon ce serait
pas intéressant non plus pour le lecteur
quoi qu'il en soit sur cette base
fictive je me suis également servi de
mon vécu du vécu de mes camarades parce
que c'est aussi finalement quelque chose
destiné pour les opérateurs pour les
opérateurs pour mettre en avant les
opérateurs c'est ces hommes de l'ombre
au même titre que tous les policiers qui
leur journalièrement et qu'on met
peut-être pas si en avant là je pense
tout de suite aux policiers de niveau 1
de niveau 2 qui était présent également
sur tous ces événements ça va de police
secours ou différents types de bas que
c'est ici à la bac 115 nous tous ses
services qu'il faut également mettre en
avant parce qu'ils ont fait un travail
remarquable et fantastique justement du
tout les hommes + fp la bac 75 ou
l'abbaye labeyrie tous et tous ces
hommes ont été des héros 7000 est ce que
vous vous en avez confiance puisque vous
vous en faisiez partie parce que vous
avez conscience d'être des héros de la
nation
l'hérault lomu est peut-être un peu fort
on n'a pas l'habitude surtout d'être
considérée
avec ce type de
voix d'hier
les policiers finalement ce sont les
héros du quotidien ils sont pas assez à
mon sens reconnus à leur juste valeur
parce que d'aider des actions
des actions fantastique en a
régulièrement va pas se mentir qu'elles
soient liées au terrorisme ou des
actions de police simple
héros finalement c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait générer pour tous les policiers
ces héros du quotidien donc la compare
les deux héros personnellement ça
résonne pas beaucoup en moi mais sans
pour autant
je suis quand même conscient de ce qui
s'est passé de ce qu'on a fait ça c'est
évident c'est pas évident c'est juste le
le terme qui me paraît un petit peu je
peux pas dire un peu trop élogieux
peut-être pas l'habitude
donc pour tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
je vous je refais un petit point donc
nous sommes en direct à l'occasion du de
l'ouverture du procès des attentats du
13 novembre nous avons nos journalistes
sur place donc esther paolini que nous
peinons à joindre mais qui est dans la
salle des pas perdus et vous dont vous
pouvez retrouver en tout cas sous son
live texte sur lefigaro.fr et qui nous
fait vivre cette première journée de
procès des attentats du 13 novembre nous
avons également thibault et or et qui se
trouve devant le palais de justice que
nous retrouverons tout à l'heure et je
suis également plateau donc avec
monsieur de paris donc philippe de paris
qui est ancien opérateur de la berri et
qui je le rappelle souhaite rester
anonyme enfin en tout cas pour la
confidentialité préfère garder son
masque et sa casquette nous avons
d'ailleurs une question pour vous
philippe de paris du chat de helix fort
et je l'en remercie et lyxor est-ce que
c'était un besoin d'écrire ce roman est
ce que c'est une forme d'exutoire ou la
volonté de faire passer un message et si
c'est le cas le quel est il dans cette
question qui revient souvent et ma
réponse est simple non pas du tout c'est
pas du tout l'histoire et je n'ai pas de
message particulier à faire passer c'est
pas vous voyez c'est vraiment une
fiction c'est un roman c'est pas un
règlement de comptes ou autres tout
simplement une oeuvre d'esprit et dans
laquelle comme je vous l'aï dit
précédemment mais je voulais mettre en
avant les opérateurs je voulais mettre
en avant les policiers mettant en avant
également le service les unités qui
gravitent autour tout en exprimant en
démontrant aussi outre le côté policier
quotidien l'aspect familial personnes
perso il vous êtes inspiré j'imagine de
votre équipe pour écrire ce roman alors
oui il ya beaucoup de traders vie de
famille fallait beaucoup de traits qui
ressorte ceci dit au niveau de la vie
familiale
ça pourrait être un mélange global de si
vous voulez ce que je voulais en
créant mes personnages c'est que tout le
monde puisse trouver une partie de lui
dans un des personnages au moins arriver
à se retrouver un petit peu après au
niveau de la vie privée c'est pas mal
fictif aussi je vous le cache pas parce
que ça aurait été à mon sens inconvenant
de me servir de la vie privée de mes
collègues pour pour pour bâtir cette
fiction donc c'est des choses assez
globalement génériques mais quand on
parle de séparation va j'en suis
l'exemple comme parmi tant d'autres de
collègues qui ont été séparés qu'ils
sont séparés à cause de leur métier en
partie way certainement apprécié
peut-être un peu trop facile aussi de
romaine tout sur sa profession mais
c'est une profession qui est quand même
particulière quand
on épouse un policier on épouse aussi
quelque part sa profession parce que
c'est un métier qui dans lequel il est
difficile finalement de ne laisser
totalement son sa journée son quotidien
à la porte de son travail on ramène
toujours une petite partie en nous et
parfois ça peut être compliqué pour la
personne de pour le conjoint de
d'arriver à comprendre le ressenti donc
c'est là dessus que la la communication
rentrent en ligne de compte elle est
vraiment primordial
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris à
faire avec le temps la communication
c'est quelque chose de très important
soit pour sa famille pour son coût pour
ses amis sans forcément rentrer dans les
détails mais sa vie déjà des fausses
croyances et certains quiproquos et je
pense que c'est même parler des choses
aussi à partir de deux camps on estime
qu'on peut donner le vrai métier à son
conjoint à ses enfants etc vous vous
rendre enfin votre expérience
personnelle vous le dit dès le départ
comment voulez vous qu'on soit votre
problème métiers du service ces deux
choses distinctes pour moi le métier du
policier du métier de policier d'élite
qui d'accord bah ça rapporte tellement
vous êtes en service du when a man par
ce moment vous êtes en ménage avec une
personne c'est difficile le cacher les
choses d'autant plus que c'est vraiment
ça c'est un investissement total ce type
d'unité pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
des créneaux horaires qui sont
complètement
aléatoire qui sont jamais régulier donc
on a des bases d'entraînement qui sont
régulières certes sur une grosse partie
il en a beaucoup parlé de l'intervention
mais à la base vraiment ce qui est notre
coeur de métier ce qui était le coeur de
métier de la de la drs c'est la police
judiciaire la police judiciaire vous
calqué sur des délinquants des
essentiellement de vols donc c'est à
vous de vous adapter finalement à leur
mode de vie et pas l inverse donc c'est
souvent des gens qui ont des vies un
petit peu
décalé qui vont beaucoup auraient la
nuit ont peut-être moins travailler le
matin ou comment se lever le matin ça va
être pour quelque chose d'intéressant
donc constamment ce décalage si vous
n'avez pas
quelqu'un lorsque vous avez des enfants
par exemple pour pouvoir pallier à ces
absences pour vous soutenir c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué donc
c'est finalement un engagement qui est
l'engagement des équipes aussi quelques
d2d tout à fait joint tout à fait vous
est ce que on le voit dans votre dans
votre roman il passe énormément de temps
ensemble à n'importe quelle heure de la
journée ou de la nuit peuvent se
retrouver pour une inter vous pouvez une
filature
est ce que est ce que vous passez plus
de temps quand vous étiez opérateurs à
berry avec vos collègues qu'avec votre
famille
si vous regardez sur les plages horaires
delà d'une journée on a tendance est
effectivement plus longtemps en
présentiel avec ses collègues que
lorsque le soir entre acteurs de famille
sont des pages assez courte puisque
forcément il faut aller se coucher donc
on a hâte de vie dans la journée on a
une famille au travail est une famille
notre famille qui est chez nous parce
que le plus important c'est quand même
notre famille justement cette cette
famille vous vous la décrivez beaucoup
dans votre roman et on imagine que c'est
c'est un des critère numéro un on va
dire de la réussite d'une équipe cette
cohésion est ce que c'est le cas dans
chaque dans chaque équipe de la berri
est ce que cette cohésion est primordial
vous choisissez des éléments en fonction
de leur caractère pour que ça ça match
et pour que vous puissiez justement
mener à bien des opérations
si compliqué complètement en fait c'est
pas le groupe de s'adapter aux recrues
se recrutent s'adapter au groupe donc il
faut trouver des personnes qui soient
suffisamment
je peux dire aléas mais qui a un
caractère qui leur permettent de
s'intégrer dans l'unité et en qui plus
est dans leur groupe donc globalement où
c'est le mode de fonctionnement de ce
groupe à la ville et les semblables donc
en termes de recrutement c'est
effectivement
un des points de critères qui est pris
en compte et si la recrue ne s'adaptent
pas on les sait on essaie dans un autre
groupe et comment comment ça marche
c'est quelque chose qui peut se faire
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
peut se faire après sa demande aussi un
minimum de transe pétition de la
personne si elle arrive pas à s'intégrer
dans un groupe
peut-être que nous on est passé à côté
de quelque chose et peut-être qu'elle
s'est trompée s'est trompé de vocations
tous aptes à voler tout à fait vrai
alors pour ceux qui nous rejoignent je
fais encore une petite piqûre de rappel
je vous rappelle que nous sommes en
direct à l'ouverture enfin l'occasion de
l'ouverture du procès des attentats du
13 novembre vous voyez sur ces images en
direct de la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris qui a été
spécialement installée donc on va dire
sur l'île de la cité à paris dans
l'ancien dans les locaux de l'ancien
palais de justice vous voyez cette foule
masques et donc des parties civiles et
peut-être de leurs avocats il y en a 350
en tout pour ces neuf mois de procès et
1800 parties civiles qui sont
invités à témoigner ou à assister à ses
yeux c'est ce procès historique
vous êtes beaucoup à nous à nous suivre
nombreux à celui nous suivre sur sur
notre page youtube mais également sur
lefigaro.fr et jeu et je vous en
remercie
nous allons essayer de répondre à toutes
vos questions si nous rejoindront si
nous rejoignons plus tard nos
intervenants qui sont sur place nos
journalistes sur place j'ai notamment
une question enfin jeudi à l'air qui
répond allusion dans le chatt
effectivement qui posait une question
pourquoi un procès aussi tard
effectivement il a fallu rassembler
toutes les pièces d'un procès
pharaonique titanesque que je ne sais
plus exactement combien il ya de pages
de dossier mais vous pourrez retrouver
ces informations sur le figaro
lefigaro.fr je crois que le dossier
d'instruction fait 542 tome tom donc 53
mètres linéaires de long de deux pages
l'équivalent de plus d'un million de
pages donc effectivement c'est a été un
travail titanesque
et l'audience va durer donc neuf mois on
va dire que ce procédé était allée sur
neuf mois jusqu'à jusqu'à mai 2022 il
démarrera toujours à 12h30
voilà vous pourrez suivre notamment les
temps forts évidemment on va pas suivre
ces neuf mois tous les jours sur figaro
live mais nous devions d'être présent
aujourd'hui pour l'ouverture et nous
offrons des live au cours de l'année
pour pour les autres temps forts on va
dire de de ce procès
revenons maintenant donc à ce livre à ce
roman philippe de paris berry les formes
de l'ombre c'est une question toute
simple mais pourquoi pourquoi ce titre
est ce que ça vous est venue tout de
suite et qu'est ce que ça signifie alors
le titre m'est venue tout de suite je
vous expliquais c'est très simple
lorsque vous êtes plastron à l'époque
c'était formateur plastron c'est la
personne qui va se retrouver en face de
la colonne pour jouer l'hostile où une
personne interpellée fin bref et que la
colonne rentrer dans une pièce lance un
assaut vous voyez vous êtes aveuglés par
la l'ensemble des lampes qu'ils
utilisent et vous voyez finalement
distingué furtivement des formes dans
l'ombre donc c'est cette image qui donc
s'est tout de suite la personne qui est
arrêtée alors ou safari enfin certains
d'en face et c'est là ça peut être un
écho aussi au fait que vous travaillez
dans l'ombre vous ouvrez à la sécurité
et à la justice du coup
un petit peu dans l'ombre à paris sa
serais bien sûr à part ces interventions
très médiatisés comme l'hyper cacher ou
le bataclan
les 99 % de votre travail il est dans
l'ombre et il est connu que des services
judiciaires
alors oui et non parce qu'il ya quand
même eu de grandes affaires qui ont
marqué l'histoire labeyrie notamment
celle de merine avec monsieur brou
sadate effectivement un petit peu mais
c'est c'est un service qui est qu'il ya
plus de 50 ans puisqu'il a été créé en
1964 donc il a une longue longue
histoire au niveau de la police
judiciaire qui est connu et reconnu au
niveau national
effectivement ça fait la une des
tabloïds
pendant de nombreuses années sur de
grosses affaires ça va du de la ferme
mesrine de merine pendant
différents enlèvement également
il ya beaucoup de violence et d'action
dans votre livre ses haltes ans et voilà
on suit les pages au fur et à mesure on
veut aller jusqu'au jusqu'au bout est ce
que est ce que c'est ça le quotidien
vraiment où vous c'est comme c'est un
roman vous avez condensé on va dire sur
une semaine la plupart des exercices que
vous êtes amené à à couvrir oui c'est
exactement ça c'est vraiment un condensé
j'ai d'ailleurs une mes collègues qui
m'a dit une semaine comme ça je signe
tout de suite c'était plutôt sympathique
mais là c'est vraiment comme je vous
l'avais dit au début de l'interview
l'idée c'était de montrer et de
condenser le l'ensemble des missions
qu'on pourrait être amené à rencontrer
encore j'ai pas tout bien évidemment sur
une période assez courte pour que le
lecteur puisse faire finalement une idée
globale de l'unité
des us et coutumes
que ce soit en police judiciaire en
intervention avec des passerelles sur la
vie personnelle et la vie de groupe
essentiellement les deux groupes alors
votre collègue dit qu'ils signeraient
tout de suite pour ce type de semaine
mais physiquement humainement c'est pas
possible de vivre autour de stress et
d'action et si peu d'heures de sommeil
en une semaine on tient pas sauf si vous
avez des préparations à au stress
intensive qui font de vous des surhommes
vous savez comment on évoquait tout à
l'heure le
hyper cacher hyper cacher ça a commencé
mercredi l'assaut et lui se terminer le
vendredi soir ça a été trois jours de
folie sept et trois jours de folie où on
s'est retrouvés constamment en louera
tournée notamment en 60 pour essayer de
retrouver à l'époque les frères kwasi
donc ça a été intense en
en énergie physique émotionnel et au
début de semaine les collègues il avait
comme leur dossier pj il était quand
même sur sur le terrain donc qu mua tout
ça objectivement ils ont une semaine de
dragons des collègues pour une semaine
de dingue ça peut exister mais c'est
quand même l'exception qui assure que
c'est l'exception heureusement
d'ailleurs heureusement heureusement
d'ailleurs et justement vous vous avez
opéré donc à paris
est-ce que vous avez constaté on va dire
sur le terrain une augmentation de la
violence ces dernières années quand vous
étiez en tout cas la berri
c'est difficile de me prononcer les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes de par les
médias quoi qu'il en soit comme ça quand
vous êtes allait bien mais on est quand
même je peux dire couper des collègues
qui sont
en présentiel sur le terrain je parle
essentiellement des bacs dès du service
général ou des unités de terrain qui est
long plus de deux capacités d analyse à
ce niveau là que moi qui suis inquiété
du moins dans ce type d'unité où on est
vraiment
focalisé sur un certain type de
délinquance et un certain type de
mission mais est-ce que vous avez champ
vous avez remarqué des changements dans
vos interventions d'aidé des opérations
différentes ou plus violentes ou de plus
de réticence un chose est sûre c'est que
la délinquance a évolué la délinquance
est beaucoup plus violente
est évoquée par ploquin année crime à
cette génération kalachnikov ou on a
tendance à utiliser la violence plutôt
que là je peux dire est communication
mais la violence est omniprésente et on
le voit encore sur certains règlements
de comptes à marseille qui ont fait
polémique sur
dans les médias cette violence où elle
est présente elle évolue
de s'adapter l'objet de s'adapter
l'adaptation justement est ce je pense
j'imagine que c'est la qualité
principale d'un opérateur à la berri
c'est une des qualités principales
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres quelques
essais sur quelles sont les qualités
requises
j'imagine une bonne condition physique
déjà il faudra une bonne condition
physique un bon état d'esprit
certaine appétence pour la police
judiciaire pour le travail ce qu'on
appelle le noir c'est à dire la tenue
d'intervention qui constitue finalement
à parts égales 50% pour chaque
thématique en termes d'investissements
et d'entraînement ta disponibilité il
faut vraiment c'est vraiment une une
profession qu'on embrasse en plus de son
métier c'est un métier dans le métier
comme dans beaucoup de services
d'ailleurs ça pourrait être le rail ou
d'autres unités de will come la brigade
criminelle également où il ya un
investissement qui est vraiment je vais
pas dire total mais extrêmement prenant
il faut bien prendre en compte que ça
risque d'impacter également sa vie
personnelle il faut prévoir en amont il
faut avoir conscience finalement de ce
qu'est l'unité
de ce que
nécessite son
son
quotidien son quotidien wii ou son
intégration voilà j'ai intégré berry ok
mais c'est pas pour avoir une tenue
noire et
uniquement il ya la police judiciaire il
ya tout ce qui va autour il ya beaucoup
de contraintes il faut s'adapter
est-ce que c'est arrivé que certains
policiers intègre la berri puis
finalement se rendre compte que il pas
les épaules ce pas le terme mais c'est
parce qu'il leur fallait ça arrivait
mais
très rarement on est plutôt déterminé
plutôt déterminé que des gens qui
n'avaient pas ya des gens qui des
collègues qui passe les sélections qui
dans une prise de conscience
effectivement lors des sélections des
voix effectivement je me se tromper ce
n'est pas pour moi donc ils ont
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de
déjà ils ont eu la démarche positive de
venir parce que c'est important il ya
des sélections il fallait tenter il faut
savoir aussi ombre
et une prise de conscience pour de la
sélection c'est tout à fait c'est tout à
fait envisageable puisque c'est déjà eu
lieu c'est plutôt une bonne chose que la
personne se rendent compte lors de cette
élection qu'elle n'est pas faite pour ça
et qu'elle décide de repartir sur une
autre direction
alors multi à ninon qui nous suit depuis
le début multi nino 05 je le remercie
sûr sur youtube et qui vous pose une
question directement monsieur de paris
qui vous demande quel est votre cv
qu'est ce que vous avez fait avant
d'être opérateur labeyrie et avant
d'être écrivain double moi j'ai commencé
par là des opc quand je suis arrivé sur
paris en 99 après je suis parti sur le
11e arrondissement aux îlots
j'ai intégré après la bac 75 n 2 nuits
dans des nuits donc et après je suis
parti à la brigade d'intervention
je passais la brigade d'intervention
c'est avec celle ci que vous êtes
intervenu tout à fait parce qu'à
l'époque simula la composante
d'intervention sur le capital qu'on
appelle la bac la brigade anticommando
cet acronyme en groupe et pour
l'intervention labeyrie et l'abbaye
et c'était avec l'abbaye aussi vous êtes
intervenu à la chair tout à fait et
c'est donc après même pour le bataclan
je faisais partie sur le compte de cette
composante bac
ensuite vous êtes resté combien de temps
à l'abbaye
je restais ans j'ai dû rester un peu
moins d'une dizaine d'années parce
qu'après si vous voulez je m'en excuse
mais ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
rentrer par la suite à la berri or à
l'époque y avait pas de sélection il
recherchait plutôt des profils au delà
la terre qu'ils avaient
une certaine expérience en matière de
police judiciaire de renseignements
également de filature donc pour me
former je suis parti à la dcrg parti
allait généraux je pratique quelques
années là haut
entre temps il ya des tests qui sont mis
en place bana ma vie a évolué je suis
passé moniteur j'ai fait d'autres
services et après j'ai pu réintégrer la
bagarre est d'intervention et
suite aux événements il ya une
passerelle qui a été fait
parce qu'il va falloir recrutement de
masse au niveau de la berri donc j'ai
suivi les sélections cette passerelle
pour intégrer la berri mais les profils
sont identiques à l'abbaye qu'allah
bénisse et c'est le même type c'est le
même quotidien que le quotidien que vous
ment pas du tout en fait là la grande
différence entre les deux unités c'est
la brigade d'intervention n'a pas cette
casquette de police judiciaire donc
c'est que l'inter que de l'intervention
à l'époque aux interventions les
d'autres missions qui leur était dévolu
sur la capitale notamment
les les points où il ya beaucoup de
tireurs de précision ce qu'on appelle
communément les snipers donc il y
assurait la protection de différentes
manifestations certains déplacements de
personnalités ils sont hyper spécialisés
dans le dans les manoeuvres de cordes
donc dès qu'il ya des interventions à
risque au niveau des escalades sur les
capitales c'est qui qui oeuvrent plus
que la berri parce qu'il ya aussi des
opérateurs spécialisés tout à fait les
interviennent pas forcément sur les
munitions
et elle existe toujours l'abbaye où j'ai
tout à fait ok donc là béhary fait appel
à l'abbaye à quel moment alors alors en
fait après les
des événements 2016 est donc ce
recrutement massif et cette passerelle
entre la bei et labeyrie et la brigade
de recherche et d'intervention labeyrie
devenus autonomes d'accord donc labeyrie
la biat disent toujours la course
émission mais qui sont dissociées de
celles de la berg
alors à scène stéphanie qui nous rejoint
dans le chat du filet rotois figaro live
sur youtube et hichem michel qui nous
dit merci pour votre travail je pense
qu'ils vous remercie vous monsieur de
paris tours voilà merci pour pour vous
il ya énormément de énormément il ya
quelques personnes également qu' qui
parle de de l'eau d'heure on va dire
notamment au bataclan comme vous avez pu
pénétrer donc dans la salle de spectacle
jlr qui dit j'ai du mal à imaginer la
vision et les odeurs en entrant dans le
bataclan est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous a marqué à vie c'est cette
vision en tout cas alors la division oui
après cette nouvelle factice je n'ai pas
de souvenirs me savais que la cagoule ça
je pense que ça filtrer pas mal j'ai des
collègues qui l'ont évoqué qu'ils ont
bien évoqué ce set cette odeur de métal
mélangée à celle du sang qui est assez
particulière
moi mon niveau ça m'a pas marqué
c'est peut-être du coup les images qui
tout à fait beaucoup plus de visuels et
l'audio peut-être enfin je sais pas
qu'est-ce que vous entendiez ce que
c'était silencieux
ce qui avait décrit dsk peut-être le
bruit qui vous a plus marqué en chacun à
son développer son sens alors c'est bien
décrits par les collègues de la colonne
alpha qui sont vraiment arrivés dans les
les premiers ou avec toutes ces
personnes qui étaient encore
c'est un magot nisand tous qui demandait
de l'aide tous ces bruits ambiants qui
avait autour mais moi quand je suis
arrivé j'ai pas souvenir honnêtement je
n'ai pas souvenir
plus marqué par les images
essentiellement les images photos alors
beaucoup de personnes nous rejoignent et
nous disent bonjour donc dans le chat je
vais je vais les saluer je vous rappelle
que nous sommes toujours en direct à
l'occasion de ce premier jour des
attentats du 13 novembre
stéphanie hassen qui nous dit courage
courage
nous avons également burgod qui nous dit
bonjour et sandrine du cerf bonjour
l'état qui témoigne encore on va dire
qu'ils pensent que les odeurs qui se
dégagent du sang doivent être terrible à
ressentir hicham hicham qui nous dit
merci à vous pour ce live et bahrami qui
nous pose une question c'est à quel
heure l'ouverture du procès alors je
vous rappelle que c'est à 12h30 que
l'audience démarre donc ce matin le
l'accusé on va dire le plus tristement
célèbres salles abdeslam est arrivé ce
matin tout comme les dix neuf autres dix
neuf autres accusés pour l'instant sur
les images en direct qui nous
parviennent des agences de presse donc
de la fp vous voyez il ya des il ya
plusieurs personnes qui font la queue
pour rentrer dans ses salles d'audience
évidemment tout le monde ne pourra pas
rentrer dans la salle principale donc il
y à beaucoup d'autres salles qui ont été
créés entièrement construite à côté et
d'où sera retransmis en direct on va
dire
l'audience principal et nous sommes donc
toujours en plateau avec philippe de
paris que je remercie de sa présence
visible de paris donc ancien opérateur
de la berri et auteur d'un polar bear et
les formes les formes de l'ombre
pour revenir à votre à votre votre livre
il ya beaucoup d'inter comme vous dites
des interventions qui sont décrites dans
votre livre quels sont les ingrédients
d'une intervention réussie
sont relativement simples pas de blessés
pas de pad éléments dramatiques
le moment c'est sans
une bonne cohésion j'imagine la cohésion
elle se fait se fait naturellement après
ça va toujours dépendre de la terre vous
savez on intervient on a terminé sous
femmes souvent sur des forcenés donc il
ya un gros travail de nego l'idéal c'est
que la personne bas face une reddition
voilà tout à fait pour éviter d'engager
les opérateurs de mettre aussi
l'intégrité physique de la personne
sécurité donc une intervention réussie
c'est une intervention qui se finit bien
également
l'accent est souvent mis dans dans votre
roman sur la difficulté pour voir
personnage de se mouvoir on va dire
vite puisqu'il faut aller vite très
souvent dans les inter avec 25 kg de
matos matériel sur le dos comment on a
en commun on apprend à gérer ça c'est
des heures et des heures d'entraînement
on fait pour ces 4 commence à ce match
est comme la billy houle avait évoqué
précédemment il faut une bonne condition
physique ça c'est évident
après vous voyez les gabarits sont
relativement différents au sein de
l'unité comme je le décris dans le livre
on a des grands là des petits on a des
costauds l'un des plus fins je suis
partie des deux partis des petits
gabarits donc pour arriver à
s'accoutumer à tous ces problématiques
liées au matériel mon travail souvent
lourd tout le temps lourd c'est à dire
en lourd c'est avec l'équipement globale
comme si on était en intervention donc
pour les pour chacun de vos exercices de
temps vous savez les 25 kg de matériel
sur vous pour la plupart oui il ya comme
ça qu'on s'habitue au matériel et puis
d'autre part ça nous permet d'avoir un
réglage optimal de notre matériel pour
pas avoir de surprise lors des
interventions tout simplement et
l'accent est également mis au fil de ses
pages sur sur les les armes il ya
beaucoup de détails sur l'équipement on
va dire de vos anciens collègues de la
berri quelle place occupe les armes
quand on est policier d'élite j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
documentation c'est qu'une très
documentaire sur sur la façon de décrire
vos équipements est ce qu'il ya une
fascination ou une
spécialisation tels que vous devenez des
experts sur les armes bâle est normal
font partie de leur quotidien dans quel
sens lui présente après fascination
japon jusque là parce que c'est encore
différent mais c'est ça notre travail
c'est un outil ultime qu'on se doit de
maîtriser complètement donc les
entraînements sont vont de pair ce soit
au tir tir j'évoque le tir au fusil
d'assaut le 416 hk 416 tirs à l'armé de
poing
tir de précision pour les tireurs
d'élite donc ce sont des pas le tir il
ya des métiers dans le métier si je plus
si je puis dire qui
des spécialités qu'on est censé
travailler et qu'on travaille
régulièrement pour pouvoir justement
être à même les employés ou pas de façon
optimale lors des interventions vous
entraînez globalement aux tirs sur une
semaine type on va dire combien de fois
par semaine c'est à plusieurs il ya
plusieurs ya plusieurs séances de tir
par semaine après ça va dépendre des
groupes ça tourne ça tourne beaucoup en
moyenne un opérateur tiers dont une
centaine de cartouches tout confondu par
semaine
certaines cartouches je me rends pas
compte par rapport à un autre agent un
autre agent c'est le double de triplets
je crois que je voudrais pas dire de
bêtises mais il me semble ça tourne
autour de 40 5 cartouches annuel ah oui
donc c'est plus cette fois sans
quasiment fin non je ne sais pas quand
je suis nul en maths mais oui
effectivement ça n'a rien à voir 45
annuel et c'est parce que je me trompe
pas je vous cacherais je peux
déconnecter par rapport au terrain pas
par rapport au terrain mais par rapport
à
ce type de formation institutionnels la
berri c'était vraiment une formation
elle est instituée une base
institutionnelle mais quand même
spécifiques et lorsqu'on est en
commissariat ou dans d'autres services
on est on est formé par les fc issy des
moniteurs qui
sait langage commun à toutes les unités
de la pub la fin tout l'ensemble de la
police nationale c'est vrai qu'au niveau
des volumes des cartouches et des tirs
qui sont obligatoires
je crois que trois tirs annuel et il me
semblait que c'était aux alentours de 15
cartouches partir peut-être que je me
trompe c'est peut-être le double mais
quoi qu'il en soit en une semaine en
gros on pourrait couvrir ce que tire un
policier annuellement
alors hk fonisk vide qui vous remercie
encore de votre témoignage sur fear
alive en tout cas sur le chat de youtube
et qui dit c'est vraiment intéressant de
voir le point de vue de quelqu'un en
première ligne merci effectivement je
vous remercie encore d'avoir accepté
cette interview on va on va continuer
encore quelques instants avec monsieur
philippe de paris d'ailleurs si vous
avez des questions sur le métier de
policier d'élite n'hésitez pas à lui
poser je vous lis et je vous vois je
relaie les questions en direct dans la
préface de votre roman donc georges
salinas qui est l'ancien chef de la
berri c'est ça sa numéro de ce numéro
deux de la berri pendant que vous y
étiez donc
il a déclaré la br i représente
l'aboutissement d'une carrière est ce
que c'est le cas pour vous est-ce que ça
a été le cas
complètement pourquoi pas ce que je vais
enfin moi ce qui me faisait rêver quand
je suis rentré enfin quand je voulais
rentrer dans la police c'était la bac
mais pas la brigade anticommando je
connaissais pas c'était vraiment la
brigade anticriminalité peut-être serait
naïf de du policier qui courent après le
voleur mais finalement c'est ce qui me
motivait c'est ce qui m'a motivé à
entrer dans la police
le le le le jour où j'ai eu mon concours
de la police mon père m'a acheté les
mémoires du commissaire broussard
c'est le hasard et j'ai lu au travers
les mémoires de cet illustre commissaire
qui a marqué la bmi
toutes les interventions de l'époque
alors ça me parlait pas vraiment puisque
j'étais plus axé sur sur la brigade
anticriminalité quand je l'avais dit
mais c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment resté en moi parce que c'était
quand même un témoignage poignant et y
avait déjà à l'époque cette vie de
groupe qui ressortait de deux sons de sa
biographie et lorsque j'ai intégré la
brigade d'intervention j'ai été
finalement mis en contact avec la mairie
et tout de suite forcément j'ai eu cette
envie de ça j'ai eu ce rappel à ce
moment là de ma carrière de ce que
j'avais lu j'ai eu envie de m'investir
et c'est pas du tout la bille labeyrie
par contre connaissait donc finalement
c'est objectivement c'est ce qui m'a
c'est ce qui m'a
mille pieds à l'étrier pour pouvoir
sur le déroulement de ma carrière et
votre père était de la maison également
pas du tout pas du tout
je vous remercie d'être en direct
toujours je vais regarder vos
commentaires sur le chat du figaro.fr
beaucoup de commentaires évidemment sur
sur notre page youtube et et je vous en
remercie
je vais saluer donc les personnes qui
nous suivent sur lefigaro.fr car nous
sommes également en direct depuis
quasiment une heure donc sur lefigaro.fr
et sur youtube il ya une question pour
vous ou encore monsieur de paris sur
lefigaro.fr cette fois 6 y at il une
préparation spécifique pour les
événements terroristes au sein de la
berri
bien sûr bien sûr ça fait partie de ce
que ça fait c'est parti ça ça fait
partie du quotidien des policiers de la
bri l'entraînement va dans ce sens mais
pas que parce qu'il ya également de type
d'intervention
que l'unité est à même de pouvoir
rencontrée ça va du force de la prise
d'otages les enlèvements également donc
c'est un entraînement qui est globale
après effectivement il ya des des des
points de concordance souvent quoi qu'il
en soit l'entraînement il est permanent
est ce que d'ailleurs cessé ses
entraînements ont été musclés ou bon ont
changé on va dire après ces événements
vous qui étiez à l'abbaye avant et qui
est passé à la berri après 2015 est ce
qu'il ya eu une évolution
sur les exercices le terme exact
pollution s'est pas réellement les
changements il ya eu une évolution ouais
pas ce concert de
l'expérience bien sûr pour pouvoir bas
nous améliorer ça fait partie de la
processus de remise en question qui est
hyper important qui est fait au sein de
ce type d'unité on sert de notre
expérience pour évoluer
alors je salue également sur le chat du
figaro etienne casselman qui fait part
de son commentaire que je vais relayé ce
procès montre aux terroristes que
quoiqu'il fasse notre justice continue
de fonctionner selon nos règles et pas
selon les leurs il ya également un autre
internaute qui nous demandent si salah
abdeslam va va parler c'est évidement
évidemment toute la question que l'on se
pose lors de ce procès il est possible
qui est qu il se mure dans son dans son
silence en tout cas s'il parle ce sera
évidemment à suivre sur lefigaro.fr nos
journalistes couvriront cet événement
bien sûr en tout cas aujourd'hui il est
présent et il doit être présent à son
procès tous les jours pendant neuf mois
nous suivons évidemment en détail ci
s'il parle ou ou s'il continue sa
stratégie de défense actuel qui est de
justement de ne pas parler beaucoup de
personnes nous ont rejoints sur sur
youtube je vais les saluts et bim bam
qui pose également la même question à
laquelle je viens de réponse vous pensez
que les accusés vont répondre aux
questions des juges donc je viens d'y
répondre nous y verrons évidemment il
n'y a pas que salah abdeslam également
19 autres accusés sur le banc
aujourd'hui donc c'est à suivre bien
évidemment sonauto foule et français
animaux qui nous suivent toujours merci
d'être avec nous et gharbi cassou
qu'ils nous rejoignent également sur sur
le chat du youtube
moi j'ai une question donc vous étiez
opérateurs à la berri dans post est
l'aboutissement de votre carrière comme
on vient de le voir pourquoi vous vous
l'avez quittée est ce qu'il ya un
événement en particulier où vous vous
avez fait votre temps
c'est pour un choix de vie personnels en
fait tout simplement donc pour une
mutation
vers une autre destination un peu plus
ensoleillé donc c'est essentiellement un
choix personnel oui c'est pas très bien
dans votre livre justement il ya un
personnage qui vit à peu près cette
situation on va dire qui approche la
cinquantaine
et le chef moi dire de l'équipe qui lui
donne des idées pour aller alors au beau
soleil justement là je dois dire j'étais
rattrapé par le livre parce que
finalement j'ai bien écrit avant de
partir ouais je n'avais pas prévu de
partir donc en fait voilà ça s'est fait
comme ça c'est des tranches de vie
auquel il faut s'adapter
tu sais bien c'est un choix
bien sûr vous écrivez à la proche
al'approche de cet âge donc dans votre
livre la proche de la cinquantaine donc
que la plupart des opérateurs commencent
à se calmer et à penser à la retraite il
ya donc aucun vieux à la berri est ce
que c'est comme chez les mannequins ou
ou chez les sportifs ce qu'il ya une
date de péremption est ce qu'on vous
déplacer la retraite
mais en fait vous voyez vous c'est
vraiment un processus personnel c'est un
choix on a des opérateurs j'ai des
collègues qui ont plus de 50 ans et qui
sont en pleine forme qui compte terminer
leur carrière au service ces gens là
c'est important de les avoir pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont finalement les garants
d'une certaine transmission dans l'unité
par rapport aux jeunes arrivants
c'est important d'avoir aussi des
opérateurs expérimentés qui reste le
plus longtemps possible pour avoir cette
transmission
constante avec les nouveaux arrivants
j'imagine que les nouveaux arrivants
n'ont plus sont pas des juniors on n'a
pas des gamins
de 20 ans
qu'ils arrivent à la berri c'est
peut-être aussi
dit que c'était un aboutissement de
carrière pour la plupart ont commencé
plus tôt on a entre plutôt plus tard à
l'abbé arrivèrent 30 35 ans je ne sais
pas exactement où je crois que la
moyenne d'âge elle oscille entre 35 et
45 ans dans sa fourchette assez large
moi à l'époque où j'ai passé les sept
petites passerelles la moyenne d'âge à
c'était 40 ans c'était quand même oui
c'est une personne que je peux dire à
s'avancer mais assez mûrs entre c'est le
policier qui ont de l'expérience
d'expérience après vous pouvez tomber
sur des collègues qui ont 30 ans mais
qui sont rentrés dans la police à 18 ans
donc ça leur fait déjà onze ans
d'expérience s'ils ont fait 11 ans dans
des départements ou dans des
arrondissements à ses actifs à ses
actifs voilà ils ont eu l'opportunité
d'acquérir
une manne d'expérience qui est
intéressant pour nous il n'y a pas de
limite d'âge quoi pourquoi pour non il
n'y a pas de limite d'âge mais après il
faut pas non plus candidate est
trop vieux si je puis me permettre
alors merci merci à vous de nous des
débats train sur le chat alors je peux
pas vous dire tout j'essaie de lire et
de voir si vous aviez des questions donc
sur le métier de policier puisque
philippe de parité avec nous encore pour
quelques quelques instants salade aux
tons qui nous demandent à quelle heure
débute le procès donc ses dents dans
quelques minutes dans une demi heure
bientôt il va démarrer
je fini de lire pour voir s'il ya une
question pour notre invité hicham hichem
qui
qui dit salade et cela mérite une peine
digne des états unis genre deux fois son
temps pour lui briser le moral voilà je
relaie son avis beaucoup de débat
justement sur sur sale abdeslam sur sur
notre chatte
j'ai une question va terminer évidemment
qu est devenu l'équipe qui a qui acquit
intervenu 13 novembre avec vous
est-ce que vous avez encore des contacts
réguliers les accusations alors précisé
rossetti parce qu'entre les que l'aide
là je vais parler uniquement pour
[Musique]
la berri à l'abbaye les collègues la
plupart sont je crois que là pour le
coup pour la berri il ya eu très peu de
départs ils sont encore en poste mais
très peu de départs les seuls départs
qui lui c'était un peu comme moi pour
des choix de vie ou des choses qui
étaient programmés qui était antérieur
du mans aux événements en termes de
demande de mutation je sais qu à
l'abbaye ça bouge aussi un petit peu
mais c'est ni plus ni moins des choix de
lier des choix de carrière
essentiellement et vous restez en lien
même si vous vous déménagez par exemple
sur un dans une autre région on est
toujours en contact c'est pas parce
qu'on pas parce qu'on se quitte ea
physiquement qu'on peut pas continuer à
communiquer mais au delà on a vécu des
choses ce soir là qui a faim cette année
là mêmes qui nous ont concret des liens
à jamais à jamais entre guillemets oui
ça comme ça et concernant votre livre du
coup pour tous ceux qui voudront lire ce
livre donc je leur montre à l'écran donc
berry les formes de l'ombre et peut-être
que raphaël à la réalisation pourra
montrer la jaquette un petit peu mieux
en grand voilà donc vous voyez le livre
en grand ici pour tous ceux qui vont le
lire ou qu'ils l'ont déjà lu ou qu'ils
l'achèteront après ce direct est ce que
vous envisagez une suite une série
peut-être avec ses personnages que vous
avez créés alors j'ai créé la suite
déjà elle est dans les mains de
l'éditeur depuis un certain temps donc
c'est en bonne voie j'étais parti sur
une trilogie généralement terminer le
troisième il ya peu après je me suis
aussi attelé à d'autres
d'autres romans différent de celui des
galeries différent de ma profession je
vais m'en vais y crée aussi de chasse et
autres et si j'aurai d'autres sujets
tout simplement écrire j'ai écrit une
fiction sur ceux des pneus aux la
sophrologie toujours sur la zone de
romanesque sur manosque écoute et
j'espère que ça va ça va fonctionner
merci merci philippe de paris d'avoir
été avec nous pendant quasiment une
heure donc sur le figaro live donc sur
notre page youtube est également sur le
figaro.fr
j'ai juste une dernière question
évidemment bon voilà c'est priorité aux
internautes un sound foule qui vous
interpelle directement monsieur de paris
quand vous partez en intervention quel
est votre ambiance j'ai cru comprendre
que dans votre livre que vous avez que
vous avez un fan de hip hop avec vous
c'est une autre ambiance
un appât coeur
le groupe dans lequel j'étais il y avait
grosse
communauté communauté circulaire qui
était fan lui qui est toujours fan
d'ailleurs de hip hop donc on écoutait
souvent du hip hop et l'ambiance et les
plus tôt je peux dire festive non quand
vous rentrez dans ce type de nuitées où
on a envie d'aller sur l'intervention ça
fait partie de notre corps de métier si
on rentre là dedans c'est parce qu'on
aime ce type d'intervention je parle pas
des interventions extrême bien
évidemment mais lorsque vous êtes
déclenché vous êtes toujours cette
petite adrénaline c'est cette émotion
qui vous font apprécier le poil parce
que c'est pour ça que vous avez signé
donc l'ambiance et les toujours même si
elle est tendue
il ya de la motivation on fait notre
travail on sait ce qu'on a à faire les
gens s'entraînent pour ça et finalement
l'intervention c'est un aboutissement
merci philippe de paris espère que il a
répondu à votre à votre question
sonotone foule nous allons vous libérer
et puis nous allons retourner sur place
en direct se retrouvait donc thibault
ysore qui est donc devant le palais de
justice sur l'île de la cité vous voyez
ces images en direct thibault que se
passe-t-il autour de vous tout le monde
et est rentré et j'imagine dans la salle
d'audience
oui alors il faut dire que tout le monde
est rentré déjà très tôt même avant mon
arrivée imaginez bien qu'avec un nombre
aussi important de personnes assistant à
ces séances eh bien il va falloir une
grosse organisation
je tenais en tout cas vous montrez bien
juste derrière moi les confrères
journalistes
on peut parler évidemment d'un
engouement médiatique internationale
mais au delà d'un certain engouement on
peut finalement dire que bien comme lors
des attentats de ce 13 novembre 2015 de
nouveau les yeux du monde sont braqués
sur paris on se souvient à l'époque
notamment à bien d'une grande attention
et d'une grande émotion mondiale qui
avait pu avoir lieu autour des attentats
qui avaient touché paris et de toutes
ces victimes et donc eh bien ce sont
désormais seuls 41 médias de 58 pays
différents qui sont accrédités derrière
moi vous pouvez voir des confrères de
cnn des britanniques de chez sky
également un présentateur arabophone qui
expliquait il ya quelques minutes à l'un
de mes confrères qu'il était
particulièrement important du monde
arabe d'être présent aujourd'hui pour
l'ouverture de ce procès symbolique
puisque finalement il ne désigne pas
qu'une qu'une tragédie locale qui touche
une capitale française mais surtout et
bien
un monde que l'on connaît avec rien le
terrorisme et toutes les questions qui
peuvent le plus cher de france mais
également d'autres pays donc voilà cette
dimension internationale assez
importante j'ai pu croiser de très
nombreux journalistes sur mon chemin
derrière moi ici mais également tout
autour du palais sur l'île de la cité
avec pour terminer comme je vous
l'expliquais un dispositif un dispositif
de sécurité particulièrement important
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi les
forces de police qui bien continuent de
quadriller la zone à partir
d'aujourd'hui et pour les neuf prévenir
du mardi au vendredi
les jours de procès
donc vous pouvez suivre en direct donc
toute cette journée sur le figaro.fr je
vous invite à consulter notre notre live
texte de esther paolini journaliste fait
divers et guillaume points j'en ai ce
fait divers également qu'ils relaient
toutes les informations esther qui est
donc qui se trouve dans le palais de
justice et qui va couvrir toute cette
première audience alors on sait qu'à
partir de 11h 23 à peu près autant
autour de 11h15 heure 23 salles abdeslam
donc le principal accusé est arrivé
sous bonne escorte bien sûr nous ne
savons toujours pas évidemment puisque
ça fait l'objet de nombreux commentaires
et de nombreuses questions savons
toujours pas s'il va parler ou s'il va
rester dans sa stratégie
mutique qui qui est là depuis le début
en tout cas une avocate des parties
civiles espèrent espère qu'il va parler
c'est samia maktouf
voilà elle espère vraiment que ça va des
slams va parler mais elle redoute que
l'accusé profite de ce procès comme
tribune pour réitérer à nouveau en
public et sous l'oeil de toul et des
caméras et de nombreuses personnes son
allégeance à d'alès donc ce sont des
propos rapportés par catherine fournier
notre consoeur journaliste à france info
alors les images que nous avons en
direct
son coupé on va dire depuis depuis la fp
mais vous avez pu voir tout à l'heure
donc la quantité de parties civiles qui
rentrait dans la salle d'audience
vous voyez vous revoyez ces images donc
là principalement on voit beaucoup de
d'avocat il y en a donc 300 350 au total
alors évidemment je ne sais pas si tous
ces avocats sont venus aujourd'hui ou
s'ils viendront au fur et à mesure on va
dire lors des autres temps forts du
procès que vous pourrez couvrir en
direct enfin que vous pourrez suivre en
direct sur nos pages je vous invite donc
à vérifier toutes les infos que voudrait
avoir donc sur lefigaro.fr il ya eu une
autre question tout à l'heure mais c'est
vrai que thibault avait répondu nous
pouvons leur contact et je vais le
joindre il ya beaucoup de questions
encore une fois si beau chez pas si vous
entendez il ya beaucoup de questions
encore une fois sur le la retransmission
en direct ou parle de ce live je sais
que vous avez déjà répondu à cette
question en début de direct mais il ya
des internautes qui se demandent si le
procès va être transmis notamment sur
notre antenne
oui tout à fait alors en direct c'est
impossible vous le savez en france on
n'a pas le droit d'accéder aux salles
avec le dispositif déjà deux films de
radio mais encore moins de trois
semaines ce qui pourrait se passer au
contraire un système comme on peut
l'apercevoir et aux états unis où
parfois certaines séances peuvent être
filmés ici impossible de suivre en
direct ce qui va se passer à l'intérieur
du palais de justice d'aller au moins en
revanche en tant que citoyen et bien on
peut venir ici même avec votre carte
d'identité pour accéder en tant
qu'auditeur public finalement à ces
séances de
justice'' thibault merci à vous on va on
va se quitter je vous remercie d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur sur figaro
là je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
reporter au figaro au figaro.fr figaro
live et que vous avez vous fait vivre en
direct les événements que vous avez pu
voir en tout cas depuis là où vous étiez
nous voyant ces images donc de là
de l'ouverture de la salle d'audience le
procès doit démarrer maintenant dans
dans un quart d'heure je remercie encore
une dernière fois mon invité qui se
trouve à côté de moi philippe de paris
donc auteurs de ce roman de ce polar
béhary les formes de l'ombre et ancien
opérateur de la berri donc à bientôt
peut-être pour une autre interview
je vous en prie plaisir c'est un honneur
et merci à vous tous qui nous avaient
regardé en direct je vous invite à vous
reconnecter sur lefigaro.fr à 17h pour
notre émission de décryptage avec paul
gonzalez qui reviendra encore une fois
sur cet événement de la journée donc
l'ouverture du procès du 13 novembre à
très vite sur figaro live